Hello, how are you, I greet you, Andrés González,
with the brief information for today, Thursday
, June 17, today we invite you to visit
our channel because it is our donation day,
you can donate any
non-perishable food, bottled water or clothes
that you no longer use, participate in this
event today  We are located at 32 28 del
Chano Late Drive and we will be collecting
donations from 6 in the morning
until 6 in the afternoon.
We are waiting for you because all natives and
especially yours count to help
and there is a new name for the
local airport but it is  transition live
started calling it
xerez read international airport however it's
not official yet the clark county commission
sent a formal request for the
change but it hasn't been approved yet
and we're going to talk about sports
as our golden knights woke up
with a tie at  one in the series
disputed with the canadian team
montreal controlled the first period of the
game and obtained an advantage of 3 an
Before the spiritual got it, the
first score for our team,
it continued with its magic but it was not
enough as a royal ended up winning
3-2 the game now governs them and they will
try to take control of the game
there in Canada tomorrow night  night
go nights cloud and now we turn to look at
the weather forecast we will have some
clouds in the valley that could bring
drizzle in the mountains for the afternoon
however temperatures will still
be above 100 degrees the
extreme heat alert has been extended until the
Sunday of Father's Day so be very
careful
remember to stay hydrated do not
leave minors or pets exposed to the sun
for several hours
I have a milestone Thursday I am andrés
gonzález and this was about the
news now in Spanish
[Music]